today is earth day and president biden
plans to announce an ambitious goal to
cut
america's greenhouse gas emissions over
the next nine
years a cbs news poll out this morning
found
53 percent of americans approve of the
president's handling of climate change
56 percent in our poll think the issue
should be addressed
right now ed o'keefe is at the white
house where the president will host a
virtual summit today
with dozens of other world leaders ed
what action do we expect
well good morning anthony the president
is set to announce the most aggressive
cuts in greenhouse gas emissions with
plans to slash them by 50 to 52 percent
from their 2005 peak doing so would put
the united states back in line with the
paris climate agreement which of course
this country left
during the trump administration the
white house says all of this is doable
in part by eliminating all carbon
emissions from our generation of
electricity by 2035
and by cutting energy costs by investing
in more energy efficient upgrades and
buildings
not clear how this will be enforced but
coincidentally many of these changes
could be made if congress passes
president biden's
more than two trillion dollar
infrastructure plan if you think there's
something to that
that's right you're paying attention the
announcement comes during a two-day
virtual global climate change summit
with about 40 world leaders
chinese president xi jinping russian
president vladimir putin perhaps the two
most notable names on the invite list
they're going to be there despite their
frosty conversations with president
biden in recent weeks on a host of
issues but notably
in recent days the us and china issued a
statement saying that the two countries
two largest economies in the world plan
to work together on climate change this
promises to be
perhaps the most consequential zoo
meeting in the history of zoom
but the world leaders understand the
gravity of the situation
today they are expected to hear from
pope francis who has spoken out
frequently
on the need for the world to address
climate change tony
all right ed the history of zoom
meetings i hope it is a relatively short
history
all told and there are costs of course
to addressing climate change but we have
to remember there are costs of doing
nothing
as well ed thank you very much